مارفينو في البياتلون للدبابات
2021 ، حسنًا ، دعونا ندعم روسيا بامرأة
المشاركين في الدبابة ubeat هو أثينا الذهبي
البياثلون النهائي للدبابات في السابع
الجيش بالفعل ما قاله المشجعون
كمية ضخمة اليوم
طاقم الدعم في ساحة التدريب
ثعبان ألابينو يُقاد من ساحة مدفع رشاش
عيار 12.7
إنهم باكو رقم 2 وهي تحوم فوق الأرض
في الواقع يرتد بشكل لا يصدق و
فاسيليفيتش جيراسيموف بكل قلوبنا نحن
نحن قلقون بشأنهم بالطبع ، لكنهم أنت على وشك ذلك
مسابقة ألعاب الجيش الدولية
سيعقد في جميع القارات
مجموع الاصدقاء في المسابقة 34
ألعاب الجيش وهكذا توقف
كل دبابة مشاركة الفريق
بياتلون أربع خزانات T-72b ثلاثة
الصينية وعلى الطاقم هو ذلك
كان هناك حاجة لتغيير الخزان أو
لم أكن من الصين وسأواصل المضي قدمًا
دورة مسابقة اللجنة الفنية
تأكد من أن الموصل المستهدف لديه مخزون
في المرة الثانية تسديدة من المنزل بشكل جيد
ويتغلب المنتخب الصيني على العقبة
ثعبان ولكن أيضًا الإضافات التي لا تزال قائمة حتى الآن
مقدما من زعيم السباق و
مسار عقبات الجسر هذا العام
وتجدر الإشارة إلى ميكانيكا صخرة الرجل نحن
نحن فخورون بكم ، فريق عمل جيد
جمهورية الصين الشعبية في ذلك ولكن أيضا
الزجاج المحطم لذلك اقلبه و
ميكانيكي سائق
رقيب لانس
جان مون الحياة عضو واحد مثل قلب واحد
لكن الضرب
شاهزودة الرابع وسائق الراية
وحدت أوسا فوج من كتائب الدبابات و
كل جيش ينتهي بنا
الكسندر نامساراييف الهدف الاول
مندهش ويكتسب الآن الخير
السرعة قبل فريق سبوك الكازاخستاني
السؤال لا يزال مفتوحا
22 ثانية عند 22 و 9 ثوانٍ عند 22 دقيقة
9 ثواني خلف
فورمان المنطقة العسكرية الشرقية
الكسندر نامكو أقوى الناقلات
عالم لا يعترف بقائد دبابة المقاطعة ش